[Musique]
bonjour à tous et merci de nous
rejoindre dans ce nouveau numéro d'
europe hebdo ici au parlement européen à
strasbourg dans cette édition nous irons
dans l'autre capitale des institutions
européennes à bruxelles
il ya tout juste un an la gestion de la
grande mosquée a été confiée aux
autorités belges après 50 ans de
contrôle par l'arabie saoudite mettre un
terme à l' influence étrangère sur ce
lieu de culte accusé de dérive
salafistes c'était l'une des
recommandations de la commission d'
enquête parlementaire sur les attentats
de bruxelles en 2016 alors comment sont
financés les lieux de culte dans le
reste de l'europe
nous en débattrons avec nos trois
invités mais je vous propose d'abord un
détour par la fraîchement rebaptisé
république de macédoine du nord ce petit
pays slaves de 2,1 millions d'habitants
s'était toujours vu refuser le nom de
macédoine par la grèce jusqu'à cet
accord trouvé entre les deux pays en
juin
retour sur la fin d'une querelle
diplomatique vieille de 30 ans avec
aurait dit à face
[Musique]
c'est la fin d'un conflit diplomatique
de plus d'un quart de siècle entre la
grèce et son voisin macédoniens à la
chute de la yougoslavie en 1991 la
macédoine proclame son indépendance
mais la grèce refuse de reconnaître à
cet état le droit d'utiliser ce nom de
macédoine
pour les grecs le terme appartient à
leur patrimoine historique
il réfère à la province du nord du pays
terre natale d'alexandre le grand
la reconnaissance de l'état par la
communauté internationale est donc
bloquée par la grèce pour des raisons
identitaires
le conflit se prolonge et au milieu des
années 2000 la macédoine voit sa
candidature à l'otan et à l'union
européenne refusait suite à des vétos
grecque en janvier 2018
les négociations sont relancés entre les
deux pays elles aboutissent à un accord
historique
athènes et skopje s'entendent pour
rebaptiser le pays balkanique république
de macédoine du nord
un an plus tard les parlements des deux
états viennent de valider l'accord
cela ouvre à nouveau les portes des
organisations internationales à la
macédoine du nord
le protocole d'adhésion du pays à l'otan
a déjà été approuvé cette semaine
et pour en discuter j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir sur ce plateau stelios
coulaud globaux jours bonjour vous êtes
grecque membre de syriza qui est aussi
le parti du premier ministre
alexis tsipras alors cette question du
nom de la macédoine est particulièrement
sensible en grèce pourquoi vous avez
l'honneur des palais avec un traître
parce que j'ai été traité comme un être
agressés en disant qu' il fallait
trouver un accord avec les la macédoine
et nord c'est une question plutôt mou
qui qui pour la majorité des européens
semblaient comme une question ridicule
alors agressé il avait une il avait une
connotation symbolique historique de 12
salles les nombres de la macédoine mais
le problème a été créée par des
politiciens débat qualité pour des
régions pour les gens nationalistes pour
profiter pour acquérir des modes de tout
ça et après ils ont déclassé une vague
nationaliste et qui était très difficile
à contrôler est ce que quand même un
sondage inquiet sortie donc fin janvier
disons que 62% un des grecs se disaient
contre l'accord oui mais c'est une folie
naturaliste coiffe parce que l'accord
tout à fait pour la grèce ou si c'est la
première fois de l'histoire qu'un pays a
obligé une autre bd changer son homme
alors on dit là on dit que c'est un
victoire ou la grèce dise non non c'est
une trahison
on ne peut pas trouver des arguments
rationnel pour argumenter avec ces gens
là qui chante pouces et pas seulement
pour les groupuscules de l'extrême
droite mais aussi bien par l'opposition
parlementaire de la droite
magog alors je vous propose quand même
d'écouter des réactions de grecs
recueillies lors d'une manifestation à
athènes le 20 janvier les gens ne
veulent pas de l'accord de trêve et
encore moins qu'un autre état a prévenu
de basse et dois je crois que c'est le
dernier effort concernant le sujet
national de la macédoine
je crois que le peuple grec doit livrer
un dernier combat
alors cet accord il est officiellement
vraiment appliquée depuis le début de la
semaine comment vous pensez que cette
accueilli en grèce gti plutôt de foot
défavorablement par y
mais pour des leçons aux qu'on n'a rien
à voir avec la la rationalité les
logiques les arguments et tout ça c'est
plutôt une folie nationaliste et qui
n'est pas malheureusement limitée
adresse
mais c'est répand dans tout les robots
alors cette question elle a provoqué
vous l'avez dit de très forts remous
politiques en grèce il ya eu donc deux
démissions de ministres entre octobre et
janvier il ya une très forte
confrontation entre à la gauche d'alexis
si presse et l'opposition qui demandait
d'ailleurs des des élections anticipées
vous pensez que c'est aussi la survie
d'annexer petit prince qui était en jeu
dans cette question et goûter ses plages
il a eu le courage des tranchées
d'avancer vers l'accord même si il y
avait une majorité des gens qui étaient
contre
alors maintenant je pense que c'est elle
est aussi le capot messier êtes les
premiers ministres d'élèves à celle d'un
énorme oui mais il ya eu de très forts
remous politiques aussi
en macédoine enfin côté macédonien
notamment la ratification elle s'est
fait à une voix près et puis il avait
quatre députés qui avaient obtenu une
amnistie juste juste avant on a
l'impression d'un accord qui passe au
forceps quand même des deux côtés
oui on en a on a beaucoup il y en a on
avait besoin beaucoup de courage
politique de ça parce qu'il avait des
propositions des deux parts et les
viseurs les choses les plus bizarres que
c'est que tous les délais régions riches
des deux côtés l'opposition des deux
côtés acquise le premier ministre grec
et à mâcher du 1er macédonienne des
trahisons 7e pas je m'étais pas ce
qu'est à la fois monsieur place aimé
césaire mérite
mais il reconnaissait nationale mérité
le prix nobel de la paix 2010 9,1 alors
cet accord il ouvre aussi la voie pour
la macédoine pour l'otan mais aussi pour
l'union européenne est ce que vous
pensez l'union européenne que c'est une
possibilité pour la république de
macédoine du nord à court ou moyen terme
oui j'ai parce que à moyen terme il faut
il faut que la mazda2 ne rentre chez
elle a comme la non européenne on a
besoin beaucoup des réformes
constitutionnelles
le structurel économique et tout ça mais
pourquoi pas parce qu'eux aussi ils
il varie toujours des gens très cultivés
et européens de toute façon pourquoi pas
et pour conclure stelios coolblue une
toute autre question se souvient donc
des images d' alexis tsipras ça la fin
de l'été à ithaque 1 qui mettait un
terme officiellement aux plans
internationaux des aides à la grèce où
on est le pays aujourd'hui
ah oui c'est ça valliot ça veut dire oui
le chômage a cité l'économie se
réchauffe
on écoute et on a beaucoup souffert
les traumatiser assez profondes dans les
pays mais quand même on en avance on
avance on a commencé à faire des
affaires des changements positifs envers
des on a augmenté les huis clos la bce
tu peux les les impôts tabac millet une
nouvelle page donc qui s'ouvre pour la
grèce merci beaucoup stelios coup le
goût d'avoir été notre invité
aujourd'hui nous prenons maintenant la
direction de bruxelles et de sa grande
mosquée gérée pendant des décennies par
l'arabie saoudite
ce lieu de culte va très prochainement
être confiée à l'exécutif des musulmans
de belgique l'organe reconnue par le
gouvernement belge un changement de
gestion recommandé par la commission d'
enquête parlementaire sur les attentats
de bruxelles en 2016 la mosquée est
accusé de transmettre une idéologie
salafistes facteur de radicalisation
comment la belgique cherche à écarter
les financements étrangers de ces
mosquées
c'est un reportage signé flora sauvage
[Musique]
c'est un bâtiment emblématique au coeur
de bruxelles à deux pas des institutions
européennes dans l'oeil des autorités la
grande mosquée était depuis près de 50
ans géré par l'arabie saoudite
mais fin mars elle va revenir dans le
giron de l'état belge
[Musique]
depuis les attaques terroristes
islamistes du 22 mars 2016 qui ont fait
32 morts et plus de 300 blessés la
belgique traque les foyers du
fondamentalisme les terroristes de
l'aéroport international et du métro au
grandi à bruxelles où les communautés
vivent côte à côte dans la foulée des
attentats
une commission d'enquêté mise en place
georges dallemagne député fédéral en est
membre l'évidence était là lorsqu'il ya
eu des attentats bruxelles le 22 mars
qu'il fallait faire la lumière sur les
circonstances dans lesquelles ces
attentats avaient pu avoir lieu à la
fois essayer de comprendre pourquoi nos
services de renseignement nos services
de sécurité n'avait pas vu venir c'est
c'est un terroriste quels avaient été
les défaillances et puis aussi et
surtout comprendre comment le
radicalisme était né dans certaines
communautés dans certaines fractions
certaine frange de la population
musulmane dans le rapport de la
commission denquête la grande mosquée de
bruxelles est pointé du doigt
en cause les prêches radicaux de ces
imams selon les auteurs du rapport
il sait diffusent des idées parfois
diamétralement opposés aux valeurs et
aux principes de la convention
européenne des droits de l'homme et de
la constitution belge au cours de nos
travaux de la commission d' enquête
parlementaire on s'est rendu compte
qu'une série de personnes qui étaient
partis en syrie avaient été en contact
avec cette grande mosquée et qui plus
est récemment un rapport de nos services
de renseignement a aussi démontré que
des manuels extrémistes servait de base
à l'enseignement en arabe de futurs
imams et donc des manuels qui appelait
carrément au meurtre la reprise en main
par l'état belge de la grande mosquée a
valeur de symbole mais sur les trois
cents mosquées que compte la belgique
seul un quart sont reconnus et financée
par les pouvoirs publics et le contrôle
s'arrête là l'état belge ne peut pas
dire voilà telle personne est légitime à
la formation nécessaire pour être imam
pour conduire la prière c'est une
prérogative du culte puisque nous aurons
ce système étrange séparation de
l'église et de l'état a oui mais tout de
même
financement public et c'est vrai que les
deux choses s'articule assez mal notre
système est je pense un vice fondamental
pour te dire parce que le système belge
qui est basé largement sur le système
concordataire comme celui que la france
connaissait avant la loi de 1905
mais le système belge à conserver les
bénéfices de ce système c'est à dire le
financement public
par contre il a supprimé très largement
la version control qui était prévu à
l'époque du concordat napoléonien dans
la communauté musulmane
on se défend de tout amalgame à la
sortie de la grande mosquée la parole se
fait rare les fidèles sont préoccupés
par l'avenir de leur lieu de culte et
par la stigmatisation de leur religion
nous sommes en tout moment l'islam qu'il
est innocent de toutes ces écritures à
être sans emploi âtre tolérant il faut
vivre en paix et ils ont donc
les grandes valeurs de l'islam ils sont
reconnus par tout le monde c'est un
poisson et les pourris on va pas jeter
de leur avis on va dire parce qu'un
point sans vie de pourri rompre le lien
avec l'arabie saoudite est un premier
pas mais l' influence des capitales
étrangères sur les mosquées belge risque
de perdurer
comme l'expliquent cet islamologue ça ne
va pas changer grand-chose soyons
honnêtes c'est à dire que l'arabie
séoudite mais aussi d'autres états du
golfe comme en particulier les émirats
et d'autres où continuent à voir leurs
canaux de diffusion donc en fait le que
ce soit au travers de l'internet de la
télévision de la distribution de
bouquins les canaux sont ouverts donc
mais symboliquement c'est est hyper
important de le faire au bout de dire
qu'à un moment donné les autorités
belges disent on met le holà
on essaye d'être un peu cohérents dans
notre approche est en fait on envoie le
signal qu'en belgique
ce n'est pas cette forme d'islam qui
doit rundschau
fin mars la gestion de la grande mosquée
devrait être confiée à l'exécutif des
musulmans de belgique
l'organe représentatif de l'islam dans
le pays une école pour former des imams
est en train de voir le jour
mais le processus va être long pour
mettre en place un islam de belgique en
europe l'organisation des cultes reste
de la prérogative des états
[Musique]
et pour en discuter j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir sur ce plateau virginie
rosières bonjour bonjour vous êtes
française membre des radicaux de gauche
en france affilié aux socialistes et
démocrates dans ce parlement européen
face à vous aujourd'hui godelieve quiz
to draw vol bonjour bonjour vous êtes
allemande membres de la cd ou et du
parti populaire européen
oui et pour compléter ce plateau j'ai le
plaisir d'accueillir aujourd'hui francis
messmer bonjour bonjour vous êtes
spécialiste du droit des religions
professeur à l'université de strasbourg
alors on le voit dans ce reportage ce
système belge avec des financement
public des mosquées mais un contrôle qui
restent partielles qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
virginie rosières ah ouais j'ai
l'impression qu'on est quand même sur un
système qui bride et qui quelque part
allez peut-être les inconvénients des
deux mondes parce que effectivement le
financement sans le contrôle c'est
mettre de l'argent public sur le
financement des religions là où on
pourrait le consacrer à d'autres
d'autres actions plus utile je pense sur
le lien social
l'action sociale en particulier et en
même temps renoncé à tout contrôle donc
c'est qu'il ya clairement un système qui
qu'ils ne le feront pas les garanties en
matière de on va dire de séparation qui
en tant que français des radicaux de
gauche qui fusaient me semble la bonne
philosophie de séparer ce qui relève du
cultuel du spirituel et ce qui relève de
la vie en commun en commun et du
politique c'est pas une solution
solution selon vous pour un financement
plus transparent des mosquées non parce
qu'on le voit bien on est la question en
attendant ce je pense à confondre des
questions de transparence de contrôle
des financements de contrôle des
influences c'est des choses qui n'ont
rien à voir avec le fait qu'il y ait des
financements publics la transparence
elle peut être atteinte par d'autres
moyens que directement la financement
public
par ailleurs ça voudrait dire à ce
moment là qu'on ne va financer soit
exclusivement par des fonds publics soit
avec des financements croisés et la
question du contrôle et des influences
étrangères restera posée exactement de
la même manière
donc je pense qu'on mélange roman de
sujets faire rentrer l'exercice des
cultes dans un cadre légal dans le
respect des valeurs démocratiques le
respect des droits fondamentaux
c'est quelque chose qu'on peut tout à
fait exiger sans pour autant avoir
recours à un financement public
alors est ce que francis messner dans
l'union européenne il ya d'autres
exemples comme en belgique de
financement public des lieux de culte
il faut naturellement faire la
distinction entre le financement des
cultes en général et le financement des
mosquées en particulier est d'ailleurs
dans ce reportage nous avons vu que le
problème principal c'était pas le
bâtiment qui a été financée peut-être
par des des états étrangers mais c'est
plutôt la formation des ministres du
culte et peut-être aussi le déficit
d'intégration de ses ministres des
cultes qui a fait qu'il existe des
prêches à caractère haineux ou subversif
et c'est pas le bâtiment en soi qui pose
problème mais la religion musulmane est
reconnu par le gouvernement belge comme
comme religion alors c'est pas la
religion musulmane qui est reconnu par
le gouvernement belge mais ce sont les
communautés qui acceptent de jouer le
jeu de la reconnaissance équipé
reçoivent ensuite un financement
spécifique qui sont reconnus un double
niveau donc d'abord une reconnaissance
au niveau de l'état fédéral et ensuite
une reconnaissance locale
godelieve christ ou de révolte c'est
très différent en allemagne par rapport
à la france ou la belgique puisque il y
à la perception d'un impôt cultuelle
mais pas pour les mosquées est ce que
vous pensez qu élargir cet impôt aux
mosquées en allemagne serait une
solution pour un financement plus
transparent mais je crois qu'on a un peu
qu'on ne doit pas confondre les deux
disons kiptoo religion les relations qui
lient à que ce soit dans le système
laïque de la france que ce soit dans un
autre système
les relations entre le christianisme en
allemagne de ce sont les deux grandes
confessions catholiques et protestantes
et les états sont des relations qui sont
passés sur des concordats sur une
tradition sur une histoire et on suppose
que ce qui est prêché dans les églises
relève de
nos principes de démocratie état de
droit etc
le problème c'est ce que vous venez de
dire qu'est ce qu'on prêche dans les
moeurs dans les masques et ça c'est la
première question quel est le contenu
qu'est-ce qu'on fait qu'elle est
l'éducation qu'on donne là dans les
écoles c'est une chose
la deuxième chose c'est évidemment
commenté ce qu on les finance en
allemagne
jusqu'à présent les mosquées sont en
gros financé par les pays étrangers la
turquie l'arabie saoudite et cetera
depuis l'an dernier en 2018 maintenant
il faut déclarer les dons que l'on
reçoit de l'étranger on est en train de
discuter est-ce qu'on peut changer le
mode de financement
mais l'idée qui est derrière cette
discussion mode financement c'était
évidemment avoir un islam qui s'adapte
quand même à nos valeurs de l'europe
élargie 7,1 pouces et c'est quelque
chose que la classe politique envisage
un débat en allemagne
oui oui on l'envisagé il ya plusieurs
types d'idées selon les partis
politiques
on est en train d'en discuter mais même
les associations musulmanes nous sommes
ne sont pas toujours d'accord entre
elles alors les différentes associations
disputent aussi d'une façon très
différente sur leur financement alors je
voudrais qu'on revienne en france 1 ou
emmanuel macron projette de modifier la
loi de 1905 pour inciter notamment
l'islam a organisé son financement dans
la transparence on écoute
à ce sujet la ministre française de la
justice le président de la république
réfléchit non pas la réécriture de la
loi de 1905 est parmi nous mais a
réellement la nécessité de redonner à
l'islam vous le savez un rôle qu'ils
soient particuliers il ne s'agit pas de
réécrire la loi de 1905
vous avez simplement des il s'agit mais
elle a été tant de fait ce qu'elle va
être à nouveau à mon il est possible
qu'elles le soient de nouveau alors
virginie rosières on sait que vous êtes
opposés à ces modifications vous allez
nous expliquer pourquoi mais je voudrais
d'abord revenir avec francis messner sur
cette loi de 1905 que dit elle
voilà la loi de 1905
c'est tout d'abord une loi
d'organisation des cultes
ensuite c'est une loi qui garantit
l'égalité entre tous les cultes et qui
interdit par voie de conséquence à aux
pouvoirs publics à l'état aux
collectivités territoriales de soutenir
une religion en particulier et de la et
de la finance et financement public des
religions en france ou via des
défiscalisations si on fait des dons à
certaines religions
alors là la loi de 1905 prévoit des
dérogations au principe de non
financement
tout d'abord le législateur a estimé que
le principe de liberté d'exercice du
culte est supérieur au principe de non
financement et donc par voie de
conséquence les personnes qui sont dans
un milieu clos honteux droit à un accès
par un aumônier qui peut être financé
donc comme comme le sont actuellement
les aumônier des prisons
les aumôniers d'appeler des hôpitaux et
les aumôniers de l'armée par ailleurs
texte prévoit aussi la possibilité pour
les communes de financer les bâtiments
cultuels propriété des communes et un
autre article prévoit la possibilité
pour les communes de réparer les
bâtiments cultuels propriété des
associations cultuelles et des
associations diocésaines donc qu'elles
existent déjà d'une certain nombre de
dérogations à l'intérieur même de la loi
de 1905 alors virginie rosières vous
avez signé l'appel des centres est
inquiète une pétition contre la
modification de cette loi de 1905
pourquoi ce serait dangereux selon vous
de la modifier cette loi on l'a vu cette
loi la satim ans vertus déjà de bien
séparer les choses et de renvoyer à
chacun ce qui lui appartient la démarche
spirituelle et religieuse relève des
croyants l'organisation de la vie
commune relève du politique et de
l'ensemble des citoyens
donc c'est bien cette sépare de cette
séparation là qu'il s'agit est entre
autres elle sépare aussi les
financements sachant que le financement
les financements publics doivent aller à
l'ensemble des citoyens et pas à telle
ou telle croyants d'une religion donc
ouvrir un changement soit disant pour
essayer d'accommoder la situation de
l'islam ce serait ouvrir la voie 1
si on veut rester fidèle à une idée de
liberté de culte et de non
discrimination entre les religions un
financement de l'ensemble des religions
et de la même manière moi ça me pose
question en termes d'organisation des
religions si demain c'est la puissance
publique qui dans un retour
effectivement concordataire mais aussi
d'organisation pas là par la puissance
publique des religions va s'occuper de
la formation des imams
qu'en sera-t-il demain du séminaire de
la formation des rabbins
pourquoi est-ce qu'il devrait y avoir un
traitement différent moi je pense qu'on
se trompe de on se trompe de combat et
on perd surtout de vue les conséquences
de politiques qui ont voulu en fait
délégué aux religions et à l'islam en
particulier
comme le disait sarkozy substituer
l'espérance spirituelle à l'espérance
social l'argent public
il doit contribuer à construire des
services publics et à amener des
services à l'ensemble des populations
est trop longtemps on a laissé se
substituer des réponses religieuse des
réponses communautaires à une réponse
véritablement citoyenne et démocratique
mais alors comment faire concrètement
pour un financement à plus transparent
de 10,4 mais encore une fois les
exigences de transparence
elles n'ont rien à voir avec le fait
d'avoir un financement public et moi j'y
suis tout à fait tout à fait favorables
mais c'est simplement renforcer les
exigences de transparence des
organisations religieuses dans la source
des moyens qui leur sont attribués dans
quelques années
quelle en est l'origine est ensuite donc
de rendre tout ça publique moi je pense
qu'on y gagnerait de toute façon quelles
que soient les religions c'est aussi un
enjeu de transparence et de démocratie
on leur impose à toute une partie de
l'activité publique c'est vrai pour
quand je disais c'est vrai pour les
mouvements politiques je ne vois pas
pourquoi ce ne serait pas le cas pour
les religions mais encore une fois ça
n'a rien à voir avec le fait d'y mettre
de l'argent public comment vous voyez ce
débat en france godelieve crise tous
deux veulent comme envoyer ce débat de
la modification de la loi de 1905
je crois que la première différence
entre la france peut-être et l'allemagne
c'est la complète séparation entre
l'état et les églises où les communautés
religieuses je prends ça 7
c'est beaucoup plus profond de moi c'est
depuis que je parle à mes collègues
français je trouve que c'est très
visible je crois qu'on en allemagne
c'est quand même plus ou moins accepté
que l'état ce n'est pas l'état qui
finance les églises ce sont des
contribuer des contributions des
croyants que ce soit les catholiques les
protestants pour l'heure pour leur
église
mais c'est accepter en gros si on fait
un sondage
beaucoup de gens disent non il faudrait
pas il faudrait que ce soit organisé
autrement
mais comme ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
tellement séparer ça c'est la première
chose la deuxième chose c'est que healy
a évidemment une discussion
transparence du financement mais je les
ai déjà dit avec l'idée qu'est ce qu'on
fait là dans les mosquées
est ce qu'on peut est-ce qu'il ya moyen
de savoir au moins que ce ne sont pas
les futurs terroristes
qu'ont-ils cogner duc et ça je crois que
c'est un problème qui est un problème
européen parce qu'il ya des actes de
terrorisme un peu un peu partout et qui
est un problème quand même beaucoup plus
récents on n'est pas tellement habitués
on sait à peu près ce qu'on doit faire
avec l'église catholique
on laissait beaucoup beaucoup moins ce
qu'on doit faire avec la mosquée
musulmane
justement à vous le disiez c'est un
problème européen est ce qu'on pourrait
envisager des mesures au niveau européen
même si évidemment le financement des
lieux de culte est laissée à la presse
bruno on est très très loin dans les
traités européens
personne ne parle d'une communauté ou
d'une compétence européenne sur les nids
sur les questions de culture ni sur les
questions de religion et je crois quand
même que c'est très bien parce que je ne
vois pas tellement de d'interface entre
la finlande et la sicile par exemple
francis messner une action à l'échelle
européenne est ce que l'action l'échelle
européenne n'est pas possible parce que
comme le précise et madame députés les
textes fondateurs de l'europe l'exclu le
lord les organisations religieuses sont
de la compétence des états nations donc
il n'est pas possible
effectivement pour l'union européenne de
légiférer sur ce sujet et donc c'est pas
tellement d'actualité effectivement
puisque les statuts des cultes les modes
de financement
les modes de séparation entre religion
et pour mieux garder contre le
terrorisme est ce que ce serait pas
logique de le faire aussi à l'échelle
européenne
il peut y avoir des actions communes
à l'échelle européenne ont effectivement
pour contrer la radicalisation pour
améliorer les formations
mais pas pour organiser les cultes le
financement des lieux de culte on l'a vu
c'est un sujet donc sensible en france
et dans d'autres états membres merci
beaucoup à tous les trois a d'abord été
nos invités merci à vous de nous avoir
suivis c'est ainsi que se termine notre
émission vous pouvez la retrouver en
replay sur nos différents sites public
sénat lcp haine et rtbf.be bonne semaine
à tous et à très bientôt
[Musique]